question 61 I mesum SI masoli their son
with the wind I want to ask you what are
your favorite books what is all the
books that inspired you to this field
and what about literature who are your
favorite authors and writers thank you
well first of all I have a lot of books
a lot of books and magazines and but
most of them are art and graphics I
don't read as much as I should you know
I just wish I could have the time to
read and I just don't do anything like
as much as I would like so most of my
books are illustrated I mean I have a
big collection of graphic art and design
books magazines graphis magazine
Communication Arts a lot of magazines
illustrations I used to take
illustrators right you say graphis
annual have a to Zed artists from a gong
to paul von deletion people like this
and big collection photography books of
Banda seen a graphic novels people can
draw so my favorite book of the moment
is a book by Paul Madonna called all
over coffee Paul Madonna and drawers is
not really a cartoon but it's an
illustration for the San Francisco
Chronicle every sunday and i found the
book in city lights bookshop in san
francisco beautiful city and these
drawings are all places in san francisco
well no people in the pictures just sort
of areas of the city houses and things
of this a beautiful drawings mainly in a
sort of brown or gray wash but then
there are little cryptic comments in the
that I really like and some my favorites
which was
sort of cast yourself in the image of
your idol pull your color tight and walk
into the storm but I my favorite one is
there's an I think it's a drawing of the
bay with alcatraz and the Golden Gate in
the distance and it says take a stand
and immediately you have a friend and an
enemy and I like that one because I
think not enough people take a stand on
things that they feel are important and
I tend to do that and probably to my
personal own personal costs but I have
to do it there are things that make me
angry and such as you know religious
instruction of small children before
they're at an age when they can
determine what is right or wrong
political dogma being flattered really
extreme values without any evidence
those are things that I concern me
people using their money to influence
political decision-making I take a stand
on those sort of things which I think
are issues take a stand on things like
Joseph rotblat to the greatest man I
ever knew personally who took a stand
against the proliferation of nuclear
weapons so those are the things i think
people should take a stand and another
book i like very much as it is by san
francisco artist Michael Schwab ooh
there's posters of the San Francisco
area and I like all the books is a book
by gamma core 123 infinity which is
quite a nice one for the scientist but I
was a kid I wrote The Brothers Karamazov
and I
read a lot of Russian writers and other
sort of had a strong effect on me but I
don't read as I say as many things as I
should and by and large they're books of
artists illustrators and Brad Holland as
a as a favorite illustrator of mine so
perhaps I should read more I quite liked
fineman's sure the meaning of it all I
think that was a very interesting book
where he talked about science and the
society and the problems posed by a
scientific education in young people who
have come from her highly dogma ties
background but those that perhaps some
of the books that I think are important
in fact when I am my family produced a
book it's a this this here is a I don't
know whether you can see it it's my
favorite book of the moment because
these are characters produced by my our
younger son David and the story line the
family have written this about this
little boy and this dog who get ten
times smaller every time they see a
pentagon and they get smaller and
smaller small and go inside the body and
this is another one where where he's
sliding down DNA so I transferred these
characters into a book which is coming
out of Christmas but in Japanese miss
going out in the English edition so I
think that'll be my favorite book in the
very near future and one of the books
that inspired me again they were
probably art books of great artists that
I like very much because I do graphic
design and so really rather different
from most people who are influenced by
books I mean I certainly
remember getting on organic textbook
fees and FISA for my birthday when I was
at school and I read a lot of that
before I went to university and was
thinking of becoming an organic chemist
at the time but I ended up as a in
physical chemistry chemical physics
spectroscopy and then in a bit of radio
astronomy and ended up doing some really
nice organic chemistry in a roundabout
way so those are the things and I think
if i were to advise a book which had
both what I was interested clever
interesting oblique observations about
life then all over coffee and by Paul
Madonna would be the one at the moment